in the lobby is Rob and Johanna hey guys
how are you
how are you doing welcome welcome it's
an honor to have you where do you guys
live we live in Nashville Tennessee oh
so we're neighbors just right here yeah
so you drove a whole 10 minutes or
something good to have you so you're
here to do your debt-free scream how
much have you paid off we've paid off
37,000 $198 18 months 18 months well
done
making what kind of income well we went
from $45,000 to $90,000 I hate it when
that happens
how'd you double your income well I used
to be a musician I'm a great teacher yes
so she made all the money and then I
prayed that the Lord would give me
wisdom about what to do next because I
wasn't earning a whole lot as a musician
huh and he said get a job actually is
great so what do you do so I work for
Way FM and during when we were getting
debt-free I also worked for Apple
part-time in the mall okay and drove for
uber at night a lot of jobs yeah hey
baby
oh my goodness what kind of a musician I
mean what do you play what do you do oh
well I'm more of a songwriter I love to
write songs and right now I do a thing
called flash mafia music it's just
organized rhyme for the good of others
father cool good for you guys yeah so
what kind of debt was the 37,000 that
was me all student loans yeah yeah she
really I didn't have any debt coming
into our marriage so it was a big
decision the merrier I'm
I'm gonna pay for so later I say out
loud that you also didn't have a job so
did you get married 18 months ago
what happened 18 months ago no I we were
at our in-laws house over Christmas
break my parents yeah her parents my
in-laws and I saw a Dave Ramsey book on
the floor in the bedroom we were
standing so it didn't look like anybody
was planning on reading reading it so I
actually they laid it on the on the
floor beside your bed I picked it up and
I thought I was just gonna read the
first page and I ended up reading the
whole book within 24 hours he was very
sociable that that's day of my parents
up I came downstairs I rushed downstairs
and I was like Joe I just read this book
we need to do this and she was like oh
no cuz she thinks I'm a pretty extreme
guy yeah when he goes he goes all in
exactly definitely does okay cool so
you're like okay we need to get this
debt paid off Joe but what did you join
or what did you say I was like okay but
not really knowing what it entailed yet
so I agreed kind of blindly cuz I'm like
you handle the finances though yeah and
she then she doesn't like to say no to
people yes to my advantage I'm getting
better
that's great yeah okay so what happened
during the 18 months what did you guys
do to get out of that well we we got the
well I got the jobs she started
babysitting me pretty much just on my
paycheck and everything that he made
went right toward debt everything okay
yeah and we we even got a roommate in
our spare bedroom to pay part of the
right thanks Jessica so that that helped
us pay off a lot of debt in a very short
time because we literally didn't see any
of my paycheck at all so as soon as we
got out of debt it felt like we were
millionaires yeah yeah so Joanna what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is I guess discipline it would
be being able to say no to people which
is really hard for me to do but when
everybody's going out and you don't have
any money left in that envelope we're
going out yeah just say no how that
works okay well congratulations yeah
thank you so much how does it feel it
feels amazing yeah we we went out and
bought a thousand dollar couch after we
got debt-free as a celebration for her
and it was nice because we had this old
plaid crappy looking couch you got it
for free yeah had character grade you
reach a point in your life where the
furniture with character no longer is
mine congratulations you should
celebrate like that you've done very
very well
thank you it added a whole dimension to
your communication I can tell and the
way you work together on this and pulled
it together and and Rob found a whole
new whole new side to his musician self
that he didn't even know he had so there
you go financial Rob very cool well
congratulations off thank you and we
wanted to say to thank you to not only
you but to your entire team
organization because we realize it takes
more than just you to pull this off and
to get the marketing and all that stuff
done that got that book in my hands yeah
so that that happens for a lot of people
around America and we really really
appreciate it and we're grateful to you
and your team at Ramsey solution well
thank you thank you the team is the
secret rewrite about that when I was
doing it by myself nobody knew we were
here so now a lot of people know we're
here is because we got this wonderful
machine around us that caused all these
things to happen I'm proud of you guys
thank you very well done Rob and Joanna
Nashville Tennessee $37,000 paid off in
18 months making 45 nope now making 90
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream 3
love it love it love it
way to go you two awesome